ich lege am anfang mal 50 er auf dem
tisch diesen hier nämlich den 5 das ist
der impfstoff wie eine impf prämie für
alle die die bisher muffelig waren aber
sich jetzt endlich impfen lassen das ist
meine forderung heute abend denn ein
ganz toller unternehmer er hier aus
bayern der macht das vor der hat ein
paar edeka filialen und sagt seinen
mitarbeitern ich zahlreichen ordentliche
im prämie wenn ihr endlich den pieks
euch geht und wie gesagt die
bundesregierung muss danach ziehen bei
dieser tollen idee und genau das jetzt
machen um die zu erreichen die sich
immer noch nicht haben erreichen lassen
von allen möglichen politiker pellen usw
wenn ich die bundesregierung hat so viel
kohle ausgegeben milliarden um
restaurants zu schließen um uns die
freiheit zu nehmen den spaß zu nehmen um
leben zu schließen und so weiter da ist
das doch richtig gut angelegtes geld der
impfung wie der rettet die impfkampagne
sage ich ja also ich hätte gerne direkt
entgegnen weil die bundesregierung hat
die blues schon richtig gesagt dass
genug geld ausgegeben und wirklich
falsche unnötige lockdown zu finanzieren
und das wären jetzt milliarden zu etwas
das wir auch überhaupt nicht brauchen
das du millionen millionen ist wenn nur
neue und es werden dann nur hunderte
millionen die wir ausgeben würden um die
gesellschaft zu spalten und dann mit
welchem ziel überhaupt dass jugendliche
dann sich impfen lassen und dafür 50
euro plus spaltet die gesellschaft
spaltet absolute gesellschaft wir sehen
doch jetzt schon wie mit so genannten
impfverweigerer gesprochen wird wie über
sie gesprochen wird dann wird das noch
schlimmer da würd mal sagen mein gott
diesen so stur und so doof dass sie sich
nicht nur für geld impfen lassen ich
will das nicht also ich finde die idee
nicht schlecht das ist ein pragmatischer
weg um wirklich schnell
die impfquote nach oben zu treiben
eigentlich bin ich so drauf dass ich
sage jeder hat jetzt ein angebot jetzt
können wir in deutschland ein freedom
day machen ich muss aber zur kenntnis
nehmen dass es viele gibt die sich da
noch große sorgen machen die da sehr
sehr vorsichtigen weg wollen und das
wäre eine möglichkeit um schnell die
impfquote nach oben zu treiben haben
einfach sagt wer in den acht wochen
nächsten acht wochen seine zweite
impfung hat der kriegt das und es wäre
mit sicherheit wesentlich günstiger als
sämtliche lockdown master über die wie
die wir über die wir gesprochen haben in
einer untersuchung die sagt wenn man das
machen würde bei 100 euro so müsste man
noch eins drauflegen würde man ganz
schnell 80 prozent erreichen bei 500
euro sogar 90 prozent der erwachsenen
ich würde es nur für die erwachsenen
nicht für die jugendlichen mir nicht
sicher ich glaube dass viele menschen in
deutschland sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen was sie an irgendwelche menschen
glauben und
verweigerung sehr sehr ideologisch auch
drauf ist teilweise und ich frage mich
was machen wir mit den 50 oder 55
millionen menschen die schon geimpft
sind also wo sind unsere prämien und ich
will kein geld ich will mehr freiheit
die haben doch ein riesenbild oft
dadurch gehabt dass sie schon so früh
gefahren also ich sehe mich dazu ich
hätte kein problem mit neid aktuell
sondern ich würde mich freuen wenn die
impfquote endlich in die gänge kommt und
man braucht dafür
ist so weiß jeder merkt wir sind alle
geimpft werden den ganzen tag mit maske
rum egal ob du mit dem zug fährt mit den
öffis oder rannte sogar fließt oder was
auch immer du musst weiterhin überall
natürlich wo du wo du dich im
öffentlichen raum bewegst du den
restaurants gehst und dergleichen einen
impfnachweis nicht nur den bringen
sondern auch die maske tragen welchen
vorteil habe ich denn davon dass ich
geimpft bin ich nehme das doch mal dass
ich dann die maske abnehmen kann wenn
wir endlich die impfquote steigt durch
diese 50 euro und dabei lockt mit der
mache ist lästig prozent sind dann sagt
karl lauterbach plötzlich leute wissen
heimat sagt das nie darauf können wir
uns einigen der sagt das geht aber er
entscheidet ist auch die fed das ist
dass du das rennen versehen das werden
wir ja das werden wir das eigentlich von
der wahl als dann wollte ich gleich noch
mal 50 er dass er es nicht wird denn
so eine aktion nur in verbindung mit dem
versprechen und danach gibt's dann auch
den freedom day weil also da kann ich
schon alle skepsis nachfolgers wir haben
damit gemacht wir haben so viele
ziele wurden bisher programmiert und
dann waren sie erreichen dann wurde doch
wieder freedom day heißt dass sämtliche
maßnahmen fallen man könnte es auch
jetzt schon machen nach meiner
überzeugung alle haben meinen im falle
erwachsenen haben ein impf angebot für
kinder und jugendliche ist corona kein
problem insofern könnten es doch machen
wie dänemark dafür wäre ich eigentlich
aber ich muss ja auch eine
gesellschaftliche stimmungen zur
kenntnis nehmen und da glaube ich damit
könnten was schnell zehn prozent
scheinen ist doch wenn wähler dagegen
ist wie er die impfkampagne ins rollen
bringen möchte also du würdest weiter
auf drängen sanierung auf angst auf
panik kampagnen setzen oder auf richtig
teure werbekampagnen des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums die ja
bisher richtig verfangen haben ja da
sind wir leider nicht aber
insofern da hast du recht die hat nicht
so toll funktioniert aber das ist
offenbar kein erfolgsweg gewesen da gibt
es andere gründe da bin ich bei herrn
mansour warum sich menschen zum großen
teil jetzt nicht impfen lassen wollen
und ich frage mich reichen 50 euro aus
das war ja gerade hier auch diese
version
das müssen 100 sein mit 200 ist noch
mehr bei 500 sind es noch mehr
vielleicht sind es bei 1000 andere aber
was ist bei einem mit all denen die sich
haben impfen lassen ist das gerecht ich
finde nicht also es muss andere wege
gefunden werden um die menschen wirklich
vom hinfallen das wird nicht das
gegenargument ist dann könnte man zur
not sagen wir zahlen allen diese 100
euro die sich haben impfen lassen damit
hätte man zumindest mal dieses
gerechtigkeit im weg und selbst das wäre
immer noch geht zeigt sich doch schon
wieder diese diese deutsche
korinthenkacker ja das hat man eine
richtig gute idee wie dieser unternehmer
in bayern er sagt ich mache anreize
endlich komm raus aus diesem system von
panikmache und ihr seid so von ungefähr
jeder unternehmer kann das machen ja
sein unternehmen kann er das machen aber
gesamtgesellschaftlich will ich nachdem
ich geimpft wurde meine freiheiten
zurück und wenn wir die menschen die
freiheiten zurückgeben bin ich
bahnfahrer fallen darf ohne eine maske
zu tragen wenn ich wieder im restaurant
drinne essen kann ohne eine maske zu
tragen dann glaube ich dass es ein
richtig gute idee um menschen dazu zu
motivieren sich zu impfen und dann
braucht man diese fünf ich nicht absolut
ist ein privatwirtschaftlich initiative
da kann man nur anregen dass viele
andere das auch machen aber die stadt
nicht dirigiert ja wer ist das denn
überhaupt im moment der sich nicht
impfen lässt immer noch der so muffelig
ist jetzt sagen sie herr mansour ja das
sind viele die an märchen glauben aber
doch nicht so viele millionen menschen
in deutschland glauben ein märchen das
ist doch viel mehr bequemlichkeit erste
habe ich auch ich glaube da gibt es ein
paar wirklich harte impfgegner die
werden wir im leben nicht mit mit 150
euro bekommen aber da gibt es auch die
zögernde die bequemen die die überhaupt
keine medien verfolgen die einfach
bisher sich nicht kurz für das thema
eindrücke haben sie nachteile dass sie
nicht geimpft sind und ich meine com im
vergleich zu mir haben sie keine
nachteile und wenn die nachteile ganz
klar sind dann glaube ich dass wir diese
menschen erreichen aber das ist
natürlich jetzt rein wieder über druck
und da finde ich so ein angebot des
weges noch ein einigermaßen
freiheitlicher weg aber warum wird ist
uns denn überhaupt als geimpfte wie
viele menschen sich haben impfen lassen
oder nicht also wer die ungeimpften sind
und ist doch gar nicht die frage die
frage ist doch wer sind die gefährdeten
und ungeimpften oder wer sind die
gefährdeten die aber dennoch zweifach
geimpft sind werden wir jetzt die vierte
oder fünfte welle im herbst und winter
haben werden die menschen die in
krankenhäuser kommen werden sind ja
nicht die ungeimpften jugendlichen das
werden auch er die doppelt geimpften
älteren seien die noch vielleicht keine
dritte impfung haben vielleicht auch die
dritte impfung und trotzdem einfach ein
geschwächtes immunsystem
dass sie trotzdem krank werden die
müssen wir schützen deswegen dieses
ganze gerede über die quote über diese
starren 80 prozent es geht nicht nur
darum wie viele geimpft sind sondern wer
gibt und ich habe lieber im quote von 99
prozent bei den variablen gruppen als
eine 80 prozent impfquote quer durch die
gesellschaft und fangen dann an kinder
unter druck zu setzen dass sie sich
impfen lässt da hat herbert reichelt rx
anderes ist die impfquote deshalb sogar
völlig wurscht verlebt würdest du so
weit gehen zu sagen die npd ist im
grunde völlig wurscht würde weiter gehen
und sagen dass die impfquote gefährlich
ist die impfquote die gerade die
bundesregierung vorgibt ist gefährlich
weil sie vollkommen wieder den fokus
davon wegklickt wen wir eigentlich
schützen müssen das ist wie dieser
lockdown für alle denen wir im letzten
herbst noch ein früher gemacht haben es
ging immer darum die wollen rabl und
gruppen zu schützen darum geht es jetzt
auch weiter menschen mit starkem
übergewicht menschen mit vorerkrankungen
menschen die sehr hoch altrich sind da
müssen wir versuchen die hohe die
möglichst hohe impfquoten hinzubekommen
und wenn wir einfach eine zahl für alle
vorgegeben dann passiert das was wir
jetzt gerade machen wir fangen an kinder
und jugendliche unter druck zu setzen
also der mv überzeugt noch nicht alle 50
prozent etwa habe ich hier in der runde
die linke seite er noch nicht béla anda
und philipp ii
[Musik]